morning in the European Parliament in
Strasbourg this year's Edition is
especially important because this is
going to be the last one before the
European elections in 2024 and special
occasion of course requires special
guests that we are very happy to have
here our president of the parliament
Madam Robert and metzola so thank you to
be here thank you very much for joining
us and really thank you that you agreed
to answer these questions that we are
receiving on our social media channels
of good people uh so first of all uh
State of the Union debate uh why is it
going to be so important this year and
what can we expect well first of all in
our annual calendar this is one of those
events addresses before the plenary uh
in Strasbourg where the commission
president together with the commission
presents
um her vision for the next year as you
said this year as the last one of this
legislature coming at the heel of a very
difficult few years first with a very
devastating pandemic and now with the
illegal brutal Invasion by Russia of
Ukraine it is one where we look forward
to a difficult challenging period ahead
in terms of legislative challenges but
one where I expect and this Parliament
expects to look forward with a plan to
reform and reboot Europe that is what
our citizens want difficult decisions
require sometimes difficult to get
Solutions but ones with visions and
courage
and what do you think that really our
citizens would like to hear from you
from you right now and what is still you
think is realistically for the
parliament such to achieve uh before the
elections last next year
well in every election such as this one
that takes place every five years unique
in the world 27 countries voting at the
same time for the same Parliament
messages are always similar this time
will be I think even let's say tougher
on the representatives first of all
decisions need to be human-centric we
need to make sure that we retain our
climate Ambitions at the top level we
need to create a safety net for our
businesses our small businesses our
Industries we need to make sure that
what we say here at the moment we are
sitting together in Brussels resonates
in each and every village and town of
the European Union that is what Europe
is all about it is not only about making
laws but is about taking decisions that
will make people's lives better how do
we make people's lives better by
addressing their concerns by listening
to them their concerns are about
migration about the state of their
personal or even Nation economies about
Rising inflation about climate about the
increase in temperatures forest fires as
we have seen you know unprecedented
number in Europe and also in terms of
environmental catastrophes this year
this is what people want to see from
Europe and I think that if we focus on
these issues and talk to people this is
my job but my colleague's job all
candidate's job I think we can come back
next year with the Parliament that is
ready to go with a reformed and rebooted
Europe really
and talking about all these issues and
reforms what is in your opinion are the
biggest successes of the parliament or
from last year well I I think first of
all the unity that we have found in
response to the war
this Parliament already on the 2nd of
March 2022
a few days after the Russian invasion
the parliament stood up almost
unanimously and said Ukraine and Moldova
should be candidate countries of the
European Union since then very
efficiently taken decisions on gas
storage on ammunition production but
also the big climate packages when we
talk about a mission trading scheme
carbon border adjustment mechanism the
social climate fund to digital digital
marketers markets acting Digital
Services act that have just come into
Force looking forward media Freedom
anti-slap will look up AI we are working
on we've worked on an unprecedented
leader in chips for example in the
criminal law area migration is still a
lot to do but at the end of the day this
Parliament has shown that when it comes
to taking decisions it can do so
efficiently promptly and also always
taking in mind and keeping in mind that
what the citizens want are very heart of
the decisions that we are taking
well and according to the latest Europe
barometer reports the interest in the
European elections is really growing
with the half almost half people think
they're interested and two-thirds are
saying they will vote uh what do you
think is the reason behind this increase
in the interest in the European world
first of all I will hope and I will work
towards an increase in that interest I
must say that it it is due also to the
fact that even during the pandemic this
Parliament was at the Forefront of of of
of pushing through the largest ever
Financial package that would help
economies recover and are still being
used to help economies recover in each
of our towns and Villages secondly I I
would say that it is us talking more and
listening at the same time I make it my
mission to travel to all countries
individual countries including my own
Malta of course and I speak to students
I speak to um uh to representatives of
different Industries I speak to climate
activists I speak to to to the
businesses and the industries I speak to
you know young people at the end of the
day even who are like me at the time in
politics looking at Europe as one where
your quality of life could increase your
protection could increase
still a lot to do not everything is
perfect we still have way too many
people who feel left alone after the
pandemic still have a big challenge of
mental health we don't
protect our marginalized societies our
minorities our communities lgbti
community
enough we also need to do much more in
those areas of the European Union that
are economically struggling today and
those people are EU citizens and they
are looking to us so their interest must
be driven by the fact of who can address
my immediate day-to-day problem can I
continue to afford to live in my house
is my government is Europe going to help
me will my children make it through
school to find a job these are all
questions that can be answered by
decisions that we take here in
Parliament and that interest must them
from there
well you mentioned Ukraine before and of
course the EU has been supporting
Ukraine since the beginning of the war
what do you think about the EU response
what do you think about the youth
support to Ukraine and which overall
should be the eu's global role
well first of all that response has been
unprecedented uh I mentioned earlier uh
the very quick decision by this
Parliament to a grant candidate status
uh to Ukraine and Moldova but which was
Then followed by a unanimous decision in
the European Council that was not by
chance it was thanks to ukrainians who
every day are fighting for our values
for our freedoms for peace security and
stability in Europe and our response can
only be to double down every day in
order to make sure that we stand by side
by side with Ukraine we've done a lot
not only in terms of political decisions
but in making it easier in terms of the
pre-accession process you know as we
gear for very
let's say pivotal Autumn where decisions
will be taken on the next steps for
accession for the parliament accession
negotiations to start already this year
if all the steps are completed also in
terms of financial assistance
reconstruction military and logistical
help there we can do much much more and
finally on sanctions this Parliament has
always pushed to make sure that the
already unprecedented packages of
sanctions that have been adopted are not
only adopted but also implemented by
everybody every country that is an ally
of the European Union that would like to
come closer to the European Union needs
to fully abide by those sanctions and we
can always go further we can always find
loopholes we can always make sure that
we plug the gaps in order to ensure that
this
crimes that are taking place every day
people a people a country that is being
targeted bombed every day that this ends
and that we can say that we have peace
on our continent once again thank you
well he also mentioned the candidate
status of Ukraine and very often we
receive messages from people who live in
the other candidate States
asking about their European path like
Balkan States
when they can expect to become members
and in the meantime how can they benefit
from the EU programs well the European
Parliament has been you know the
strongest Ally if we look at Ukraine and
Moldova and Georgia Western Balkans we
have always said that and this is not
something that we just say but we really
believe in it is that a larger European
Union is a more secure more stable more
free continent and I can say this from
personal experience where I went through
or lived in a country that saw the
transformative effect of being an
applicant country to a candidate country
to a pre-excession country and then a
member states it will soon coming on 20
years of membership next year these
countries my country together with nine
others and then later with Romania
Bulgaria and Croatia the changes that
they have seen have been enormous the
rise in Stan ended up living and quality
of life and access to opportunity
opportunity in rules better rules for
protection
is nothing that would have been possible
also in terms of financial stability
without the European Union so my message
to all those countries is that yes each
country has its own path but you will
find in this house your friends that
will always think of a larger European
Union as a stronger and more stable one
and climate change climate change is of
course a very important topic 77 of
people saying this is the most pressing
issue right now so how is Parliament
fighting the climate change and we have
been the biggest proponents of having
the most ambitious climate legislation
on the planet I would say you even have
other continents looking at what we are
doing how we are managing to keep that
balance between being climate ambitious
and making sure that our populations are
still with us when we put forward such
ambitious legislation if you think about
what we have done for example in the
social climate fund where we made sure
that our small businesses continue to be
protected even when regulation would
impose additional costs when we look at
certain legislative legislative
instruments that are necessary but might
need for example a little bit more time
for enforcement in member states but at
the end of the day and I respond those
77 and this especially after a summer
where we saw the effects of climate
change everywhere I don't think there
was one country that could Escape those
effects in terms of either visibility
but living in them we talked about
forest fires we talk about flooding
flash floods also mudslides these are
all climate phenomena that never used to
take place so rapidly or so often in the
past this is a a reaction of a changing
climate and what are we doing about it
this house not only legislates but
spreads the message and goes to
different parts of the European Union to
say how important it is to take those
sometimes very difficult decisions yes
they need to be cushioned yes they need
to be explained but at the same time
necessary because we only have one
climate one planet and we are the last
generation of politicians that that have
the possibility to do something about it
and we cannot lose that opportunity
well migration is that migration is
another very important topic it keeps
being on the headlines we keep hearing
either we discuss about the integration
or we keep hearing about ships that are
they're sinking in a Mediterranean or a
little bit English Channel
what do you think about the youth
migration policy can it improve somehow
who we are coming to 10 years of what
the audience will remember as a
lampedusa tragedy when the Mediterranean
Sea was called by Pope Sir Francis as
the largest cemetery in the world
what have we done since then that is a
question we need to ask all of ourselves
when is our migration policy going to
become one that is truly fair with those
who are eligible for protection that is
firm with those who are not with a very
coherent returns policy and that is
Harsh with those who seek to prey on the
most vulnerable people on the planet
Smugglers traffickers
we have on the table a packed a package
that ticks all these boxes it is up to
us now to put the legislation on place
we are moving in the parliament we have
moved quite rapidly on this because we
have understood the last election in
2019 migration was the topmost concern
of many of our population so we need to
be able to say in 2024 that we delivered
on those concerns now is everything
perfect absolutely not will we manage to
resolve all our issues and treat all
countries the same of course not
different countries have different
realities whether you're a Frontline
State whether you are you have a c
border a land border whether you get
secondary movements in other words
people entering irregularly in your
territory and then moving country these
are all
geographical National situations that
are being tackled on a national level
but in our case we have legislation that
can streamline procedures that can
create a nest of protection if you ask
me I would like to go further I would
like a system where you can apply for
protection from outside the European
Union in order to prevent from the
almost certain death wants to try to
cross a sea we are not there yet but
with strengthened external border
policies would a solidarity mechanism at
its core I think we can find that right
balance
we also receive many questions and
people are noting that the cost of
living in Europe is really growing and
salary is not always keep up with this
so how can we make sure to keep the
Europe's economy growing but and at the
same time remaining competitive for
being competitive this is something that
needs to be done also at a European
level we need to give member states
what one would call flexibility
even if not within the legislative and
Regulatory framework but also when we're
discussing country by country in terms
of use of cohesion funds regulatory
rollout of what is needed at a national
level we need to cushion the social and
economic impacts we are still feeling
the social and economic impact of
migration we are still feeling the
social and economic impact of the
pandemic and we are feeling uh are not
making the the link between where we
need to plug the labor market gaps and
persons who come to Europe because they
need a future they come to Europe for
Hope and when our citizens tell us and
they are right at telling us the burden
is too much
we feel like we are being strangled we
feel like we have a brain drain our
young people are leaving they have no
future in their country we get this from
countries in the European Union we get
this from countries that are neighboring
the European as well we also tell get
businesses telling us I have no option
but to move my my production line
outside of Europe I want to have a
Europe that remains a home for everyone
remaining competitive while cushioning
those social and economic impacts that
are hurting our individuals our elderly
generation Our women in uh in the
European Union that are still far away
from having the level of equality that
we need that we met with men in our
Union
and one last question to you today uh
free and open media is crucial for
democracy and what is Parliament I mean
we have many journalists that making
sure that those people you know who are
in power that they have put on the
account and how what is parman doing to
make sure that the journalists are
protected and that we still have a free
media
this has been a priority and you can see
with the pictures behind us uh mostly
since 2017 when Daphne carvana Galicia
was assassinated uh in in Malta and a
few months later yank
was assassinated in Slovakia together
with his fiance Martina Kushner there
the European Parliament stood up and
said we cannot have a union where
protection is given in many different
areas where an analysis of is done for
member states in their economic field in
the Justice field but not in their media
Freedom protection of journalists fields
and we found a loophole and we filled it
in European Parliament adopted an
unprecedented
anti-slap which is a strategic lawsuit
against public participation which are
losses that are used against journalists
essentially to to to scare them from
from holding people accountable from
searching from the truth and we now have
a law on the table that has been
negotiated with the council if we had
not started that in the parliament I
don't think that would be on the table
today we're also going to vote the next
days on the beta Freedom Act this is an
unprecedented piece of legislation that
seeks to create as far as possible a
common field still very far away I would
like us to be more ambitious I would
like us to to be able to find a good
middle ground where all member states
can Implement such a such a a law
because it will impact different member
states in a different way because of
different systems that exist but for me
it is clear the European Parliament is
at the Forefront of the protection of
journalists has always been and will
always be
well thank you very much unfortunately
this is all the time we have today he
already took lots we took lots of your
time so thank you again for your answers
that is clearly a lot that has been done
and still needs to be done and we look
forward to our next next conversation
with you and in the meantime I also
invite everybody to follow the State of
the Union debate next week which will
happen in the European Parliament on
Wednesday at 9 00 a.m you can find more
information on our social media channels
and at your repair dot Europa dot EU
website as well so thank you again thank
you and have a nice day